[Musique]
bonsoir alexis donc entrer en vigueur un
demain de l'obligation vaccinale on l'a
dit une exception
quasi exception je dirais française en
europe quel est l'état des lieux
aujourd'hui alors il ya les états unis
un bien sûr qui eux veulent pour le
personnel fédéral
m la vaccination new york également est
à new york en europe c'est différent la
france a choisi et ça c'était annoncé
dès cet été de vacciner les populations
au contact du public chez les soignants
pompiers mais pas les policiers ça
c'était l'exception que qui est acquis a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre on a 2 7
millions de soigner en france on ne sait
pas demain combien ils seront à ne pas
être vaccinés certaines sources parlent
de 12% ne soit 300 milles environ
soignants et personnels d pad qui serait
non vaccinés et donc qui se vont se
retrouver tout simplement suspendu qui
ne pourront pas travailler qui n'auront
pas de salaire il ça pose un problème
bien sûr puisque la question c'est
est-ce que l'hôpital peut continuer
comme ça est-ce qu'on n'aura pas une
crise de manque de bras alors que déjà
on a vu cet été les urgences étaient
fermées par manque de soignants donc
c'est quelque chose qui va qui va poser
problème évidemment
le gouvernement lui se montre ferme
qu'il a dit de toute façon c'est la loi
et c'est demain doit d'exception puisque
là on est dans une loi qui est plutôt
contre le droit du travail plutôt qu'une
loi sanitaire et qu'est ce qui se passe
est bien là demain si jamais vous n'êtes
pas vacciné et bien vous serez suspendu
alors olivier ferrand a même demandé à
l'assurance maladie d'aller traquer ceux
qui seraient en arrêt maladie faculté
enfin faux arrêt maladie pour pour les
sanctionner davantage donc on voit bien
que c'est un bras de fer que qu'il
engage le ministre avec les soignants
qui rappelons le lors des premières
vagues et bien été envoyé au front un
pour soigner sans masquer les masques et
est moisi étaient détruits sans outil de
protection quasiment et sans vaccin
évidemment
donc les choses ont beaucoup changé
c'est un combat où certains médecins
apporte un du grain à moudre
l'affectionnent anna karina les cons qui
s'est fait remarquer aujourd'hui si vous
ne souhaitez pas vous faire vacciner et
bien changer de métier le messager et
est clair il est clair mais c'est plus
compliqué que ça chère madame lacombe
parce que des vaccins obligatoires il
m'a déjà beaucoup et les soignants les
fonds sans rechigner là la question qui
se pose sur ce vaccin est pourquoi
certains le refuse c'est que ils ont
peut-être déjà eu la maladie maintenant
on voit des articles scientifiques qui
disent qu'une infection vaut quand même
une certaine protection et qu'une dose
suffirait la question aussi de
l'efficacité de la couverture vaccinale
sur le long terme combien de doses
va-t-il falloir canton et soignants en
particulier donc on peut comprendre que
certains se posent des questions et puis
derrière ce problème finalement deux cas
c'est le droit du travail avec ses lois
d'exception permanence sous prétexte
sanitaires ça fait qu'on va se retrouver
avec un hôpital malade encore plus
malades qu'avant il ya un an de ça avant
le coup vite deux ans c'était les
urgences qui manifestaient dans les
urgences ça va pas mieux aujourd'hui on
a vu à l'appel de la cgt et d'autres
syndicats plusieurs milliers de
soignants qui étaient dans la rue pour
protester devant le ministère de la
santé demain il y aura des mobilisations
également de citoyens et de soignants
devant les hôpitaux les ars l'idée c'est
de dire en fait qu'est ce que vous
voulez on a là certains leaders
syndicaux disait une loi de
discrimination qui n'a aucun sens d'un
point de vue sanitaire donc c'est la
vraie question d'autres disent que les
soignants qui font ça ne pense pas au
bien commun etc etc mais à partir du
moment où ce vaccin ne permet pas ou
alors limite certes la lal contagiosité
mais ça ne sert empêche pas néanmoins de
pouvoir redonner ce virus le transmettre
et puis un autre problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus de 80 mille
postes sur pôle emploi dans le domaine
de la santé un qui sont les aides
soignants les auxiliaires de santé les
professionnels de santé qui sont non
pourvus donc on est déjà avec un métier
qui n'attirent pas forcément les foules
qui ou la rue de recrutement est
difficile puisque le temps de la
formation et l'on est là que fait le
gouvernement une loi ubuesque de plus
pour dire aux gens eh bien vous ne
travaillerai pas alors qu'on a besoin de
vous c'est là on marche vraiment sur la
tête je sais plus vraiment quoi dire
mais il ya quand même quelque chose dans
ce jeu de poker menteur parce que
si jamais demain il y avait beaucoup
trop de problèmes dans les services
d'urgence ou dans les services de soins
des hôpitaux le gouvernement a prévu une
porte de sortie qui est dans la loi une
loi qui permettrait finalement de
suspendre cette obligation vaccinale en
fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie
donc comme on voit que la courbe est
déjà quand même descendante 1 et toutes
les courbes le monde depuis plusieurs
semaines il se pourrait que si jamais
vraiment on va au clash alors là le
gouvernement lâche du lest et c'est là
que c'est un peu un poker menteur eric
c'est autre chose un des centres de
vaccination qui vont fermer cet automne
signe du succès de la campagne oui alors
c'était une annonce aujourd'hui
effectivement les centres de vaccination
qui ferment alors soit c'est le succès
évidemment il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
sont fait vacciner soit c'est aussi
l'essoufflement de la campagne vaccinale
est toute la question maintenant c'est
est ce que les pharmaciens les médecins
vont pouvoir prendre le relais et à
quelle hauteur avec la troisième dose
les primo vaccinés qui veulent pas le
faire les autres et c'est donc les
affaire mais je crois que surtout
pourquoi on ferme c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement ferme rester vaccinodromes
il ya une volonté politique aussi de
clore l'épisode du coc vide je crois que
ce qui va faire qu'on va s'en sortir
c'est d'abord la volonté politique de
dire j'ai géré la crise de la part d'
emmanuel macron et d'olivier veyrat
redon cocorico on a gagné on était les
meilleurs ce qu'ils disent depuis le
début alors que les chiffres compte
quand même le contraire et donc on va
sans doute arriver à une fin politique
de cette épidémie parce que la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi
nous sommes encore dans un état
d'urgence sanitaire alors qu'on le voit
depuis sa part resté bon ben ça fait
plus de 18 mois donc on est on a mis la
démocratie entre parenthèses le
président gouverne avec des conseils de
défense sanitaire il ne rend de comptes
à personne alors ça arrive quand même la
cour de justice de la république demande
agnès buzyn l'ancien ministre un
décompte ce sera peut-être le cas
d'edouard philippe d'olivier ferrand on
va voir comment ça se passe ne voit bien
que politiquement à la fois il ya des
voix qui s'élèvent contre ce pass
sanitaires donc ça va pouvoir devenir un
enjeu de la campagne présidentielle
d'une certaine façon et que fait mme
nelles macron depuis quelques semaines
maintenant et bien il est en campagne
même s'il ne le dit pas donc là
clairement pour couper l'herbe sous le
pied de ceux qui pourraient regagner à
dire que le pass élitaire doit s'arrêter
bien on va peut-être dire que c'est fini
et qu'on va gérer cette épidémie comme
une politique de santé publique comme
une autre et donc pour ça il va falloir
dès novembre arrêté avec cet état
d'urgence permanent merci à l'équipe
oullins